[Applause]
[Music]
Puerto Rico can't catch a break as if
the savage economic crisis that has been
suffering for more than a decade its
declaration of bankruptcy and the
devastation wrought by hurricanes
Irma and Maria in 2017 weren't enough or
now they have constant earthquakes to
contend with so far there have been more
than 2,000 recorded seismic movements
since 2019 and they've continued into
2020 I don't know what else could
possibly happen next on this island some
good luck perhaps because that seems
like the only thing they haven't been
hit with however what stands out most is
that sometimes this place seems more
like a territory in sub-saharan Africa
than an incorporated territory of the
United States itself so what makes me
say that you ask as you know Hurricane
Maria caused enormous chaos from which
the islands more than two years later
has still not fully recovered and we're
not just talking about the more than
3,000 lives that were lost the hurricane
left the islands without electricity for
weeks in some areas electricity was not
restored until 11 months later in
addition more than 90,000 houses were
destroyed and damaged all kinds of
infrastructure was enormous let's be
honest for a hurricane to cause damage
is something that we can predict for the
aftermath to take years and years to be
fixed and for the chaos still to be
widespread that's not so predictable
or at least you wouldn't expect that to
be the case in a territory that belongs
to the United States would you
and let me highlight this here we are
talking in some cases of almost one year
without electricity sure these things
may happen in the developing world
that's to be expected but in the United
States really the fact is that all these
natural disasters came at a particularly
difficult time for Puerto Rico as we
told you in a previous video that I'll
link to in the description in 2015 the
islands government had declared
bankruptcy and the economic situation
was bleak really bleak and right then to
make matters worse the island was hit
with not one but two hurricanes and
that's exactly what we're going to talk
about in this video what the post maria
puerto rico looks like how the situation
was dealt with and what future we can
expect for an island that is going
through what is perhaps the worst period
in its recent history
the aftermath of Maria beyond the
figures two devastating hurricanes in
less than one month first hurricane Irma
that hit the island in the north and
later Hurricane Maria that hit it with
tremendous force something like the
final hook of a boxer who's about to be
Kayode
now as a Caribbean island Puerto Rico is
very exposed to this type of phenomenon
and it's natural for hurricanes to cause
damage that's perfectly clear the point
is that given its per capita income and
level of development the island suffered
far greater consequences than it
theoretically should have and the
question we have to ask ourselves is
well why did these hurricanes cause so
much damage wasn't Puerto Rico prepared
to deal with such emergencies and why
did it take so long to rebuild and then
when the rebuilding was done the
problems still continued in short what
exactly happened with Puerto Rico that's
the question that we want to answer well
better understands what occurred on this
island we can take a look at what
happened to the electrical system in the
aftermath of Hurricane Maria for a
particular area of a territory to be
without electricity after a hurricane is
understandable and to some extent it's
normal
however for a whole islands the size of
Puerto Rico with more than 3 million
inhabitants to be out of electricity
that's a different story
it's a clue that things weren't exactly
going well before the arrival of the
hurricane and the truth is that's
exactly what we need to look at Puerto
Rico's electrical infrastructure was in
a precarious state it was something
you'd expect in a developing country but
not what you'd expect in a free
incorporated territory of the US thus
due to poor planning and especially poor
maintenance a storm took out at least a
quarter of the electricity transmission
towers and disabled 40% of the
substations the result was a complete
blackout to make matters worse the power
production systems are on the opposite
side of the islands of the major
consumption centers let me explain that
while 70 percent of the fossil fuel
plants are in the south seventy percent
of the demand is concentrated in the
north which is where San Juan the
capital and some other heavily populated
towns are located
this distribution requires that the
connections are well protected something
that as you can see was not the case on
the islands in fact the high voltage
line connecting the production centers
to the consumption centers was shattered
when the hurricane passed in short the
damage was enormous and it meant repairs
took a long time now at this point many
of you are probably thinking well behold
on Simon why so much insistence on
Puerto Rico's electrical system well
that's because it serves as something
like a stress test a case study that
illustrates the pathology that really
hides at the core of the problems that
this place experiences and look I'm
talking about problems that we can find
not only in Puerto Rico but also in many
other places in Latin America
[Music]
predictable collapse
the Puerto Rican electrical system has
essentially been a publicly owned
company since the 1940s
in fact s-- government company the
electric power authority had a monopoly
on distribution and electricity
production until 2010 and today it
continues to be the most important
player on the island and you know what
this situation mirrors almost everything
that happens in this place
unfortunately in 2017 this monopolistic
public company went bankrupt and it's
pretty difficult for a company that has
a monopoly on a basic service to become
bankrupt but well that's exactly what
happens the fact is that it did so just
a few months after the Puerto Rican
government's own declaration of
bankruptcy which was the largest
government bankruptcy in the history of
the United States
and the reasons for both bankruptcy
filings were pretty much the same on the
one hands the extravagance lack of
accountability and incompetence of local
politicians played in the central role
let's not kid ourselves here in the end
the blame usually lies closest to home
[Music]
but in this case they weren't the only
ones fault in a way it's a story we've
told you before on visual politic the
United States also played a key role in
both bankruptcies huerto Rika wheeler
Puerto Rico is something we've already
talked about the enormous ly precarious
situation in which Puerto Rico currently
finds itself is due in addition to the
island's incompetent governments and
rampant corruption to the abusive and
crippling laws which the semi-colonial
territory is submitted to by the United
States take for example the case of
preper the electrical power Authority
the 2017 bankruptcy which was filed just
a few months before Anna and Maria
descended onto the islands was primarily
due to the 1996 deletion of section 936
of the US federal government's internal
revenue code
what did the sections say well it
basically granted exemptions in federal
taxes for companies located in US
control territories such as Puerto Rico
in the case of this Caribbean island a
period of ten years grace was
established as a transition phase until
the total elimination of these tax
incentives could be established this was
a process that was completed in 2005 so
what do you think happened next exactly
just a few months later a huge crisis
ensued puerto rico lost all kinds of
investments particularly industrial
investments it was truly massive to give
you an idea a whopping 60 percent of the
electricity company's industrial
customers just left the island
[Music]
of course this quickly led to an
increase in unemployment poverty and the
informal economy and this sequence of
events meant electricity consumption
plummeted something this in turn caused
a sharp decline in the accounts of the
public electricity company
[Music]
and if they're management's already left
a lot to be desired now they had to deal
with a huge drop in revenue a black hole
of truly epic proportions in this way
not only did The Electric Power
Authority begin to accumulate huge
amounts of debt but any modernization
transformation and even non urgent
maintenance plans were put on hold in
fact the company even cut costs in
ordinary maintenance tasks and still
nothing was enough to prevent the Power
Company from going bankrupt 10 years
later
[Music]
in other words we're talking about a
company that was sunk by the
mismanagement of puerto rican
politicians and by the decisions of
those in washington a very toxic mix and
it was a mix that eventually blanketed
the whole island
maybe puerto ricans not having a voice
or the right to vote in the US elections
as a contributing factor and don't tell
me the odd story that they elected a
kind of spokesperson to represent them
in Congress do not be fools if you don't
have a vote it doesn't count
so Puerto Rico is a territory completely
overlooked by the United States although
they are officially a part of the United
States it is more fair to say that they
are under the rule of the American
superpower in any case what does seem
clear is that Washington politicians
don't trust each other at all and they
trust Puerto Rican politicians even less
and on it goes
given the history of corruption the
misuse of public funds and its poor
internal management's hardly surprising
but Puerto Ricans don't do much either
they prefer to say nothing rather than
change the situation proof of the extent
of this mistrust could be seen after the
impacts of Hurricane Maria at the time
the then Republican majority United
States Congress in accordance with the
Trump administration forced Puerto Rico
to create a reconstruction plan that
would be tightly audited by the Puerto
Rico oversight board a federal agency
set up to monitor government accounts
after the island declared bankruptcy but
not content with that the US authorities
also imposed a series of very demanding
and almost unprecedented standards for
example any contract in excess of ten
million dollars for reconstruction had
to be closely monitored by the board
something that may sound like a good
idea but which in practice caused a huge
problem the board is not exactly winning
any races in task completion in effects
what Congress did was to bureaucratize
all the reconstruction tasks to truly
crippling levels
well you could say what seems like a
good idea turned into a bureaucratic
nightmare
Puerto Rico was rocked by Hurricane
Maria ruined by FEMA's negligence
reviled by Trump USA today and it
doesn't end there another example of
this mistrust is the extraordinary and
unprecedented requirements imposed on
the Federal Emergency Management Agency
FEMA and the Department of Housing and
Urban Development HUD ie the two federal
agencies responsible for distributing
and managing disaster recovery funds
among other things in April 2018 the
federal government imposed a spending
limit on these agencies that could not
be higher in any case than the estimate
of costs made by the government of
Puerto Rico for reconstruction in other
words they wanted to avoid overspending
at all costs
thus if unforeseen events or unexpected
situations appeared during the process
Puerto Rico would just have to wait and
I'm sure this may also seem like a
reasonable move right at least until you
realize that it's basically an
invitation to overestimate the damage
and inflate reconstruction budgets which
is exactly what the government of Puerto
Rico did but that leads us to a debate
that would need several videos to
untangle with the point is that as you
can see throughout the entire process
these measures gave the impression that
the federal government was much more
concerned with controlling puerto rican
politicians than with the timely
restoration of the islands and essential
public services
so can the u.s. be blamed for this and
why does it all seem so
dodgy well let's take a look what
illegal from bad to worse of course
Puerto Rico's problems don't all stem
from federal laws that are totally out
of touch with Puerto Rican reality
however to make centrist statements is
really only just skimming the truth the
truth is that for many years the various
governments on the islands have
completely neglected spending on the
very serious financial problems that the
island had and have devoted themselves
instead to basically asking for more and
more money from the United States
Congress the aftermath of the hurricanes
gave us some indication of the extent of
their incapacity just take a look at
what happens in the weeks following the
catastrophe input to recall containers
full of goods sit undistributed at ports
National Public Radio and friends don't
think for a moment that we're talking
about isolated cases in fact in early
2020 numerous pallets of humanitarian
aid given after Hurricane Maria that had
not been distributed were discovered at
a warehouse of course by then many of
the products were out-of-date what the
rico emergency director fired after
residents discover warehouse full of
hurricane maria supplies CNN and sadly
that's not the first time
[Music]
in fact this inability to deal with
problems and constant suspicions of
corruption have been and still are a
vicious cycle the result is that even
today in one forgotten corner of the
United States many homes are still
damaged and many roofs are still covered
with blue tarpaulins so given such a
backdrop you won't be surprised to know
that the harsh crisis that began in 2006
continues today the government public
accounts remain in almost as bad a state
as when the country declared itself
bankrupt in fact you could say the
Puerto Rico is beyond needing an auditor
or an accountant they could just skip
straight to a taxidermist further the
mass exodus of Puerto Ricans to the
United States has reduced the population
by more than 600,000 people since 2004
anyway as you can see between one thing
and another the island is falling apart
what happens to the Electric Power
Authority is a good reflection of what
happens to this territory as a whole so
at this point the burning question is
how can Puerto Rico get out of this well
perhaps the United States would have to
put aside its paternalism lands allow
this territory to be managed with full
autonomy for better or for worse at
least that way local politicians will
have no excuses in the meantime any
adjustment plan won't make much
difference either if the model is not
changed on a fundamental level
you can't expect results to change
either but what do you think how do you
think Puerto Rico can escape this crisis
if you'd like to leave your opinion in
the comment section below please do so
so I really hope you enjoyed this video
please do hit that like button if you
did don't forget to subscribe for brand
new videos also please do check out our
friends at the reconsider media podcast
they provided the vocals in this episode
that were not mine also this channel is
possible because of patreon and our
patrons on that platform please do
consider joining them and supporting our
mission of providing independent
political coverage and as always I'll
see you in the next video if you want to
learn more about politics and world
affairs and here's some more of my
lovely voice come check out the
reconsidered podcast where we don't do
the thinking for you find reconsider WW
re consider mediacom or on Apple or
Google Play or your favorite podcast
[Music]